Now comes the interesting part because the answer is 2^n⁻¹.
The important thing to notice here is the following.
You still have two possibilities of visiting this part here. So there's still two possibilities.
And you also have two possibilities for this part here and all of the other ones in between as well.
But here something interesting happens.
If we choose to travel up here then down here then it cost us one extra edge to visit clause #1
as opposed to if we had gone from this vertex here to this one directly.
Just one extra edge. Now what would happen if we go down here?
If we were to visit this vertex immediately then we are over here, which means we haven't yet
visited these two vertices here so we need to go backwards, then up here, and then back.
Something like that--so this is not going to be a false path because we're starting to visit
cities multiple times and even if we tried to do it another way so maybe just visit this here first
then we can't go down here again because then we would again visit cities twice.
Also going over here, then up here, then backwards through this
and also revisit this city here twice.
What you can see is that on a shortest path if we want to visit this vertex down here
then we must take this route.
If we do not have to visit this vertex, then we don't have to take this route
then we can still chose arbitrarily.
The number of shortest paths between A and B, if we have to visit that vertex, has been reduced
and that is pretty neat because that means we can only visit this vertex here on a shortest tour
if we are going the right way and now you can already see the relationship.
If we connect this clause here to this part here, which represents a variable in the right way
so that we can only visit this city if the variable is set in the right way
because we said going up here means true, going down here means false,
then we can ensure that a shortest path from A to B visits this vertex here,
which means that we can also have a satisfying assignment for this clause here.
And I'll illustrate this for you in more detail.